we have a distinct advantage in this
question because it very much resembles
this one we did here you see that okay
namely that causes negative so again I'm
in the second or third quadrants but I
might say that cause is negative
therefore theta is second quadrant okay
so to get my base angle this guy here
I'm going to go cos inverse and I'm
going to ignore that side seven over
eleven okay which excuse me has anyone
wonderful Baxter than me I'm getting 50
degrees okay so there's my approximate
angle to the nearest unit okay so what
am I gonna do in the second and third
quadrants it's going to be 180 take away
50 180 plus 50 okay and it actually is
worth writing that down rather than
going straight to what the actual answer
is the 130 which is the first one or
what's going on - 30 it benefits you to
put this slide down that's why I'm
putting it down for two reasons at least
number one it shows that you understand
what you do with these and you're not
just pulling these out of the hat and
secondly if you happen to get these
wrong and you're going back and try to
work out what happened okay if these
answers come out of the net it's hard to
work out you know what the problem was
whereas this it's like oh I accidentally
took away 40 instead of 50 or I added it
instead of subtracted or whatever it
might be the more working you have there
the easier it is to diagnose what's gone
wrong
how come you don't go to 70 minus day ah
okay great question so why am I going
because you've got 180 here and 360 here
why not 270 good questions so I'm going
to now appeal back to the there we go
the unit circle that's a very good
question if you're asking the same
maybe you want to draw a unit second
with me as well doesn't have to be evil
beautiful but okay now do you remember
when we were working out okay I want to
stop thinking about causing side just in
triangles I mean obviously in triangles
but I haven't drawn many today right I
want to think about them just as angles
sitting out on their own
now it's why we introduced this guy the
unit circle okay but we had to start
with triangles because trigonometry
right so we began here in the first
quadrant and I drew a triangle like this
hope you remember it okay it looked like
that right here's my right-angled
triangle okay and you find them in the
unit circle the hypotenuse is one
because it's a unit radius right so
there's the radius and then if you use
that as theta okay you find out that
this distance along here is cause and
this distance up here is something and
that's when we get these coordinates
from okay so so far so good you remember
this right and when you go over here to
the left hand side okay what kind of
triangle would you draw that would be
equivalent to this right and the kind of
triangle you draw would be one that is a
mirror image like so okay it would look
like that right now the reason why it's
important is because if I could feed it
here the actual angle that I've gone
around on the unit circle has gone from
here all the way around to here you see
that if I drove it all the way from here
over to here okay so if I have theta in
this little triangle here right what's
the size of that green angle we have
another board right it's 180 take away
the little a right because 180 is the
straight line do you agree with that so
I've called feet out why don't you -
even in this supplement now that's in
the second quadrant
when I come down to the third quadrant
what will the triangle
look like okay now the triangle is again
just like this was a reflection over
here okay this is going to be a
reflection down this way sorry
so there's my right angle triangle now
if I want fear in there it's been okay
so now my green angle is not going to
stop here
rather it's going to start from the
positive X's enter all the way around to
here okay now can you see why look from
here to here there's 180 right all the
way around that be 180 and then to get
to the actual angle I want I add finger
so that's why this is 180 plus theta
what would it look like if it was 270
takeaway I'll just show you it's got to
look something like this unit circle
triangle one triangle shoot there's 270
right so to go backwards from there I
would draw this triangle that just looks
wrong okay it's like what happened to my
beautiful I'm actually gonna get a
butterfly when I finish this up right so
you can see to get if that's the arm if
I wanted the actual angle to be 270
takeaway feet on the triangles in the
wrong spot for the actual angle I want
okay so 180 plus last one quickly to get
my last four quadrant I'm going to again
take down this way right
if theater is there on the inside okay
and I call them all the way around fear
how close am I to get good 360 and the
answer is a necklace theta right so I'm
360 takeaway theta and so that's the
explanation